foreign
I'm Dave Rubin and we are live on the
YouTube with another Friday panel
Extravaganza for you today we're going
to be talking about what's going on up
North with our neighbor and Canada it
seems like there's a lot of strange
things happening up there we're going to
unpack all of it and joining me to
discuss are the host of the Michaela
Peterson podcast Michaela Peterson good
title for a podcast the founder of Rebel
news Ezra Levant and lawyer turned
YouTube commentator which is the best
thing you can possibly be Viva fry
welcome to the Reuben report everybody
good afternoon great to be here thanks
for having me on all right I've got
three Canadians uh two in Toronto
Michaela and Ezra and Viva you are in
Montreal there there's a lot of weird
stuff happening in Canada we're going to
spend the half hour talking about it but
just briefly when we all connected each
one of you have your own story about a
little bit of tech censorship
demonetization that sort of thing Ezra
you're in the middle of a massive battle
right now so let's just spend like two
minutes discussing how we've all battled
through that Ezra can you just update
what's going on with the rebel and
PayPal because it doesn't sound great
sure on Friday at 6 00 PM so after work
hours we get a terse email from PayPal
just cutting us off they don't say what
we did wrong what rule we violated what
action we did we've done over 150 000
transactions with them over 8 million
bucks perfect customer relations we've
never had a complaint and for five days
we've tried to get them on the phone or
by email our lawyers being so friendly
what went wrong can we fix it
stonewalling us so yesterday we decided
all right that's enough we're going to
sue for breach of contract and uh
interference with economic relations we
are going to sue PayPal in Canada
because the way they're conducting their
business is just too high-handed so wish
us luck yeah well you've got you've got
luck for me and I think from these guys
that you're going to need a little more
than luck so it's good you've got a
lawyer and actually I'm talking to a
lawyer right here Viva does this guy
have a chance can you fight PayPal and
win well from what I understand PayPal
has arbitration clauses so they may have
to go through arbitrary but no this is
it's it's egregious it's over the top
people say you know private Enterprises
can do what they want they still have to
behave uh fairly and they have to on the
one hand respect their contracts and
they have to have Fair dealings with
their customers especially when you have
a business relationship and not just a
platform like YouTube or you know they
tolerate you but Ezra's problems are
next level
um compared to most of us you know I've
had the occasional video demonetized and
it's it's random it's arbitrary some
might say it's politicized but you know
but for that it's a little lost Revenue
that I know YouTube is still making
Revenue off of uh but you know that's
been the extent of my problems although
all content creators are just sort of
walking a line on YouTube you want to
get your message out you want to speak
but you don't want to be shut down and
have your voice shut off sure and the
demonetization thing of course is a soft
type of censorship because it's not
direct censorship they're not stopping
your videos although when your videos
get demonetized we know that hurts them
in the algorithm so less people see them
but I would say it's so often that we
all have to make a living and you know
that if you talk about certain things
and can't make money on it well then you
may talk about those things less
Michaela you've had some problems with
that too right
yeah last year last July I got covid and
I released a video about my experience
with covid which was like 18 days of a
flu and about a week after that my
entire channel was demonetized and I
didn't get any messages it was just
demonetized I contacted YouTube
um I was dealing with other things at
the time so it wasn't high priority but
I was just remonetized last week
without warning for no reason I have no
idea what was going on there but I'm I'm
happy to have monetization back but that
was like almost a year the entire
channel so basically eight months of not
being able to make money on the podcast
that is your main vocation yeah so I
think I think everyone gets that but
let's let's shift to the main focus here
which is Canada so you guys all know
this I've spent a bunch of time up in
Canada I I toured with Michaela's Dad up
in Canada I love visiting Canada I think
the people are wonderful there's an
expression of Freedom up there that's
great and it's just a great country and
you've got room and there aren't a lot
of people which is nice it's all just
wonderful up there except something
ain't right guys something has happened
in this last year Ezra I'll throw to you
first what is going on we're going to
show some video in a moment but what
what would you say the general
temperature is in the in the north at
the moment
well our political class has become
uniform what do I mean by that there are
10 provinces each has a government and
an opposition but all the governments
and all the opposition parties even if
it's a liberal government or a
conservative government they're all in
favor of the lockdown so you have no
political dissidents at all whereas in
the United States you've got to run
DeSantis on one side and the Gavin
Newsom on the other side you have 50
different approaches in Canada it's
uniform secondly the media is completely
into the lockdowns they're cheerleaders
for it finally travel in and out of
Canada even to the U.S which used to be
so commonplace is extremely restricted
and I think they're making it difficult
on purpose 14-day lockdowns when you
come home you have to go to a covid jail
basically stay at a covet Hotel
quarantine Center for three days they're
trying not to let people travel so add
in complete political uniformity media
uniformity and no one can see what
America or the UK are like this country
is like a hermetically sealed lockdown
North Korea and I know that sounds
insane but there was just a study the
other day that showed that Canada is in
a strange League of countries like North
Korea and China for extreme lockdowns
there's no political diversity here and
we don't have Iran DeSantis up here we
don't have uh skeptical media it's the
agreeableness of Canadians which is
normally so nice yeah this is a terrible
time for everyone to be so agreeable
with such a bad thing right and I think
perhaps your problem with PayPal might
have a little something to do with the
fact that you actually have been
reporting on this stuff over at Rebel uh
Viva you're in Montreal and I've seen
some just absolutely crazy videos about
lockdowns and you know times that you
have to be indoors and just all sorts of
banana stuff it's a you know we say it's
a slippery slope it's a slippery slope
until you hit the edge and then it's a
free fall and you have in Quebec or
Premier Lego in January declared a
four-week curfew and I'm putting
four-week curfew because we're now into
month four of it and it was it was in
imposed at the time to stem a rise in
cases not to overwhelm the hospital icus
over the holidays we're four months
later from what I can tell now the
number of people in the ICU and
hospitalizations are lower than what
they were at the time and the discussion
is not even how are we still in this
curfew it's there's no discussion as to
how long this curve is going to last it
just goes from react you know
preventative or reactionary to
preventative to permanent responses from
the government and people you know some
people protest some people are objecting
to this but a great many aren't the when
what Ezra says you know the media is in
the bag of the government
I listen to daytime radio they're beyond
cheerleaders they are getting going to
you know agree to accept this is going
to be the new Norm it's not so bad it's
for our own good and when you realize
that you know the federal government
funds the CBC to the tune of a billion
dollars or something a year they're not
gonna bite the hand that feeds them in
Quebec our government is you know paying
for covet awareness which is Radio
placements television placement
advertising radio and television which
are star for ad dollars they're not
going to complain about this so it's
this incestuous relationship where the
government funds the media the media
props up the message of the government
and you know proverbially shuns anybody
who dares to disagree yeah Michaela are
you shocked how quickly even though as
Viva said you know Canadians or sorry as
Ezra said you know Canadians are nice
Canadians are friendly they're open
they're decent they're tolerant but are
you still despite that shocked how
quickly it seems like so many people
have just folded
well if you look on social media and on
the response to this I have seen the
negativity towards it growing so before
when it was like hey you know the reason
we're still in a lockdown is because
you're going to visit people like stay
at home so people were angry at each
other for for not staying at home and
I've slowly vaguely seen that change
into you know this has gone on long
enough how long is this going to
continue we've been in a stay-at-home
mandate for months like the downtown
area I I live in a condo downtown and
it's a mess there are tents everywhere
there are some parks that have outhouses
in it because there are so many people
in tents if you walk down Queen Street a
whole bunch of the stores are boarded up
it's really sad and really depressing
and people are scared but I think people
are slowly starting to get angry but I
mean it's taken
way too long like we're way past what's
reasonable at this point so yeah I'm
like I'm saddened and surprised yeah and
I I mean as recently as a couple weeks
ago I wanted to go to Toronto so that I
could interview your dad and they
weren't even allowing international
travel and do you guys know is that is
that still the case I'm guessing it is
right
the court just upheld the uh the
quarantine mandate at these government
designated quarantine facilities the
court says you know said it's a it is a
reasonable measure to protect against
the risks of international spread of the
virus um you know we've that was the
other thing by the way media supports
the government that subsidizes them and
the courts thus far have you know not
been courageous enough to say at some
point we either live in a free society
and we either have a constitution or we
don't but when these infinitesimal risks
can warrant or Justify forcible
confinement in they call it a hotel but
it's located in a hotel the courts are
sanctioning this and so yeah there's
still in effect and the courts basically
gave it the blessing it's just
extraordinary so I do want to point out
though that you guys aren't the only
three people fighting back because even
though Canadians are nice and smiley and
welcoming we're seeing tons of it on the
street in terms of pushback so we're
going to throw to a compilation video
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I was on public property
is not an essential reason
I like to speak what's on my heart you
have to wear a mask if you don't you're
going to be detained
[Music]
she's just carrying a sign that's all
that's unacceptable in Canada
what was her name gosh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I mean it's just evil stuff you guys
have seen this I'm sure most of the
people watching I hope most of the
people watching have seen some of this
Ezra you guys if it wasn't for rebel I
probably wouldn't have seen half of the
amount of stuff that I've seen and I
have no problem saying like this is Nazi
style tactics when you have people that
are just following orders arresting
people for expressing themselves can you
give me a sense of of the types of
people that are out there I know the
media will probably these are far right
Wingers out there right they must be
racist people or something and they're
far right Wingers but I suspect that's
not really the case you know what's so
interesting I see a realignment when
Robert F Kennedy Jr when Naomi wolf who
have typically been regarded as
Progressive are worried about this you
have people who are more into Natural
Health you have people who love working
out you have small business people
people who opened their dream was to
open a restaurant lots of working class
folks For Whom the lockdown isn't great
there's a lockdown class they love it
because they've got a nice big backyard
maybe they got a country home it's a big
staycation for them watch some Netflix
order in fast food but what if you're in
a small apartment with no backyard and
yet you're not allowed to go out because
there's a curfew in Montreal a City
built for going up and about and so I
think that calling them a right wing
there are some conservatives who are
skeptical of the state definitely I
would call myself that but I have never
worked with more people on the left who
are against police uh you know out of
control police
and let me just go through I was just
thinking of a list of people who would
normally oppose police brutality
you would have the opposition silent you
have the media silent you would have
courts silent you have law professors
you would have our version of the ACLU
the Canadian civil liberties Association
silent and now you have the Canadian
government introducing an YouTube
censorship build called Bill c-10 and
I'm thinking why why now because that
Last Vestige of individual dissidents is
on social media including our own
YouTube channels
um the the police in Montreal track our
guy Yankee Pollock they call him Jew
media they they've issued him dozens of
tickets they for thousands of dollars
they've slammed our people against cars
handcuffed them taken them to police
stations where is the left and I I so I
think that things are actually some
Canadians who love this authoritarianism
they find it they find it thrilling yeah
and Ezra over this over the winter I was
at the park where they had just put in a
new um toboggan run and there were some
journalists there and you know speaking
of the people who love this I overheard
the journalists having a discussion you
know talking about the lockdowns and
then saying well what are you doing this
weekend oh I'm going to my house in the
Eastern townships yeah and
there are people who support it because
they're benefiting from it because it
doesn't harm them as much as other
people but I in my own day-to-day
discussions with people who I don't say
that I'm on the right but I know these
people are on the left they start to
turn around quietly the problem is
nobody wants to Bear the brunt of the
public you know opposition of this so
you know they support quietly and and
they encourage quietly but they don't
want to have their faces on this
and it goes beyond not being in
opposition Aaron O'Toole the
conservative opposition uh of Canada you
know won't won't trigger an election so
that we can at least you know Duke this
out in the election uh uh side of it uh
and he's as much supporting of these
measures as anybody else so yet you
don't have any politician except for
Maxine Bernier from The People's Party
of Canada fighting these measures or at
least openly protesting these measures
and I I don't use the Nazi analogies I
don't like them they always they're
easily misunderstood but Jason Kenney
the premier from Alberta I think it's
like two or three years ago tweets out
something very you know critical of
China of how the con you know a human
shield being built around a church and
this is how you fight communism and
three years later he's literally putting
up barricades around a church and
imprisoning locking up for over a month
a pastor a Christian Pastor all because
he's holding services and so you fight
the you fight the demon long enough you
eventually become the demon and it seems
our politicians have become the demons
yeah so I want to get to the pastor in a
second because it's just an insane story
but you mentioned Maxine Bernier and you
know I I did a couple events with him in
Canada and one of them went really viral
when there was this elderly woman in a
in a walker trying to cross the street
and they're yelling at her that she's a
Nazi and of course it turns out that her
husband actually fought the Nazis in
World War II but but his ideas and the
ideas of the People Party of Canada are
looking pretty good right now because
two three years ago they were screaming
about freedom but uh Michaela Ezra
mentioned bill c-10 I think you could
probably link some of this stuff back to
Bill c-16 that your dad was talking
about four or five years ago because he
didn't want the government to compel
speech and in essence right now you have
the government cracking down on people's
speech
yeah and this one is I would say this is
far worse than the Bell my dad was
fighting against because that was just a
little a little area of freedom of
speech that he was focused on and this
is YouTube
censorship for the country of Canada
it's absolutely absurd I hope it's not
going to go through I don't see that
going through but I'm also way more
positive I think than perhaps the other
two guys in this conversation what's the
reason for the positivity like what
what's the thing that you see in the
distance that gives you hope
I can't imagine that people in Canada
want their YouTube censored like you'd
think that people could self-censor if
they don't want to watch a video then at
least they should have the option to say
no I just don't see that holding up in
court what do you guys think do you
think that's actually going to go
through well actually and Dave for the
benefit of your audience who might not
know what bill c-10 is yeah a little
further yeah it's an act to amend the
broadcasting act which would uh which
would impose the obligations on Digital
streaming uh the same obligations that
are imposed on traditional media radio
and television which is a certain amount
of it has to be Canadian created
Canadian theme uh you know failing which
there will be certain penalties or
sanctions so originally bill c-10 was
intended to exclude user generated
content on social media YouTube Twitter
Facebook Etc the liberal government
discreetly quietly in the midst of a
pandemic removed the original exclusion
that they had included so now bill c-10
would in fact govern user General rated
content on platforms like YouTube so if
you know I'm a Canadian I could not
create any more Canadian content except
I talk a lot about American stuff so in
theory I could be required to talk about
a certain amount of Canadian materials
or my channel could be suppressed or
de-prioritized because it's not in
compliance with this bill C10 and the
regulations the requirements that are
currently imposed on traditional Legacy
Media like radio and television right so
in essence I think we're probably all in
agreement that Michaela's right the
people don't really want this but I
think what you're all sort of saying
here is you have a political class that
actually doesn't really care Ezra
well look uh the CBC this was alluded to
earlier
is the largest news organization in
Canada it gets a government budget of
about a billion and a half dollars a
year so extrapolate that in America that
would be like a 15 billion dollar a year
Grant to let's say PBS it's larger than
all private news media combined so it's
the dominant player still that wasn't
enough for Justin Trudeau so he put all
the newspapers on a bailout so about 99
of the media in Canada are either owned
by the government were subsidized by the
government about last one percent are
the Grassroots Independents and I put us
in that category and a few other small
guys but that so irks the PM because as
long as there's one voice
uh it it can start an it can snowball
and
that's C10 which would seek to regulate
YouTube it would be like if the FCC in
the United States regulated the same way
they would regulate Howard Stern when he
was on terrestrial radio if they could
regulate your YouTube channel but it
goes further give me 30 seconds on this
data we have a Heritage Minister I call
him the censorship Minister because in
His official mandate letter like his job
description from the Prime Minister the
first point is give money to
broadcasters I'm not kidding you can
look it up the second point is bring in
uh enormous Financial punishments for
social media companies that don't take
down harmful posts within 24 hours that
is literally the second priority for the
Heritage minister in Canada so what
happens if you have a 24-hour period any
accusation you can't have a due process
the government's compelling Facebook
YouTube Twitter Google Instagram to take
harmful not illegal harmful things down
within 24 hours and the minister said
that includes taunting politicians and
he said he said this that one possible
remedy he calls the nuclear option he
said this at a Canada 2020 conference
includes the ability to block people
from even uploading things this sounds
like North Korea that is what Justin
Trudeau proposes to Canada it's a
reminder that he always loved Castro
that he said China was the country he
most admires Dave Justin Trudeau has
been telling us who he is for years he
really is that guy he really does want
to regulate even private Communications
YouTube Twitter Facebook it's real but
Ezra he wears cool socks isn't that
enough to be prime minister Michaela
what do you think people actually think
about this guy like do you meet people
your age that are like oh yeah Trudeau's
doing a good job or is it simply because
his suit fits nicely and he wears
colorful socks
I don't think people are very happy with
him at the moment especially with the
stay-at-home mandate most people no like
no one likes the stay-at-home mandate at
this point in Ontario so people aren't
happy with him I do I do think that he's
operating out of a place of fear though
like I I told you I'm I'm more positive
in my way of thinking I don't
necessarily think there's something
truly evil going on I would err on just
plain stupidity and fear uh because I I
think that's the clearest option forward
I I think I've heard our Premier talk
about you know if I do anything else
it's political suicide you know it's
causing actual suicides but for him it's
political suicide so I think a lot of
people are operating on fear and I think
because Canadians are such a polite
people that like these guys said people
are scared to be the bad guy and they're
just waiting waiting for it to end but
it's headed in a whole hopefully it
recovers when the vaccine rollout
eventually happens if that happens it's
not like they had a year to prepare for
anything else but
they had a year to prepare but they
Blame A disruption on the rollout on a
four-hour protest in Montreal last
weekend wow I don't worry about the
intentions of the the political leaders
I don't know if it's incompetence or
malice the outcome is the same so the
the intent doesn't matter yeah it is I
did a live stream with our journalist
George samueli the other day and we were
talking about Putin and we were talking
about the trial of navalny in Russia and
my audience was saying oh that trial was
a sham trial and George Samuel was
saying yeah the trial was okay and here
I'm sitting like thinking our
politicians what separates them from
other dictators in the world is only the
level of politeness with which they come
down with these edicts but but for that
the outcome is probably worse here and
the measures here are worse on the
general population than they are in
other parts of the world that we have
traditionally regarded as totalitarian
or fascist regimes yeah and you know it
comes down with a smile a nice haircut
and a nice set of socks that can
distract us from the Tyranny well it
seems like the politeness part of Canada
Canadians actually can only be pushed so
far because an estimated hundred
thousand people showed up in Montreal to
protest the lockdowns I mean that's an
incredible amount of people for for a
country that you know usually is not
protesting it's government but I want to
touch on the the pastor situation
because this is just incredible let me
let me just read this to you a pastor
from Alberta Canada awaits a May trial
in prison after refusing a bail
agreement that would have forbidden him
from preaching James Coates who pastors
Grace Life Church in the Edmonton area
was first arrested in February after the
Royal Canadian Mounted Police repeatedly
flagged his church for refusing to abide
by public health orders that capped
attendance at 15 percent capacity guys
I'm not a scientition but 15 percent
means that covet can't spread right
that's the magic number and that's why
he should have abided by it Ezra day
fact number one there was never a single
case of covid in his church let alone an
outbreak uh fact number two he served 35
days in a Maximum Security Prison
because of that by the way 400 inmates
from the same prison were let go for
coveted reasons because they were in
danger they put the actual criminals out
of the prison the pastor in 35 days and
by the way being convicted of this
health order not closing your church
does not even carry with it a jail term
so he was jailed out on bail waiting for
a trial the worst consequences of which
would not involve him going to jail
riddle me that one when he got out of
jail the police were so worried that the
church would Recon reconvene that they
did a dawn raid on the church erected a
large fence around it and have since
then expropriated the church and had a
continuous 24-hour a day Garrison of
heavily armed police because they don't
want the church retaken it looks like an
outpost in Afghan understand that the
police permanently occupy this church
now I should tell you one last thing
that's the craziest of all not the 35
days in the Maximum Security Prison not
police expropriating and turning a
church into a base but this church meets
every Sunday Dave
in secret in an underground Church in a
secret location
that's China stuff Dave that's that's
Pakistan that's India a secret Church in
hiding from the police in Canada in 2021
and by the way
I expect as soon as tomorrow another
Pastor in Calgary named Arthur pavlovsky
maybe you've seen the video of him
saying get out and get out
he has an order that takes effect while
today actually and if he doesn't shut
down today he risks being jailed as soon
as well today can you mention his name
again because these videos are
absolutely incredible what is it sure
it's a Polish name Arthur
a-r-t-u-r pavlovsky
p-a-w-l-o-w-s-k-i and and we've actually
I should tell you we're crowdfunding his
legal defense he's got a bunch of
lockdown tickets and we crowdfund civil
liberties lawyers form so I have an
interest we're trying to help Arthur
pavlovski but he is very stubborn that
the pastor in Edmonton who went to
prison for 35 days he did so he turned
himself in they would have let him go
anytime he just would not in his
conscience stop calling people to church
but he was very peaceful like a dove
this Arthur pavlovski in Calgary is more
like a lion you heard him Roar he will
not go quietly I I think it's insane but
you were about to see a second Pastor in
free Canada in 2021 imprisoned using
public health as the excuse that's what
Canada is looking like today so the
videos of him are absolutely incredible
and actually we'll link to the GoFundMe
down below and and I'll donate to it and
I'll I'll promote it on Twitter as well
I mean it's just incredible but that
Viva to something you said before that
is why I don't mind actually calling
these guys Nazis not that they want to
necessarily round people up and put them
in camps yet I suppose but I understand
why you don't want to just everyone
labels everything Nazis and all that
stuff but the actions the way that these
people I'm just following orders I mean
we know that was the excuse that the
Nazis used in the Nuremberg trials right
and it's like you watch these people and
they're doing bad things in the name of
just following orders well I I just I
don't use the analogy just because you
know it
it evokes certain reactions which are
exactly why people use them Archer
pavlovsky uses them and he coming from
you know where he came from you can't
you can't argue with him when he's going
to use this because he has seen the the
I guess the regression from free into
tyranny
um but uh Ezra you forgot one thing in
the church I think they put latrines you
reported they put latrines porta potties
on the front steps of the church and you
know it's it's it's not it's like
disrespect disregarding and crushing of
the spirit and like Ezra said you know
they locked up the pastor for 35 days
the underlying charges never themselves
carried any jail time so they get him on
the breach of bail conditions which is
the only infraction that results in the
prosecution that could result in jail
time it's it's the classic if they don't
get you on the substance they're going
to get you on the procedure and you
would have been safer at his church
statistically than elsewhere
you still have people saying just hold
all the rules it's religious people
thinking that they have special
exceptions I'm not religious but if you
forget the fundamental sanctity of
religion then you are one step closer
towards justifying pretty much anything
yeah yeah go ahead
the trial you mentioned of that Pastor
had happened this week in our report of
Sheila gun read covered it there was a
moment in the trial she told me about
that was incredible
um the public health inspector kept
going to this church in Edmonton they
were extremely peaceful I've been there
they're just all love and hugs and
everything and she went there several
times and she testified under oath she
was not afraid at all but then one day
she came back with a bunch of heavily
armed police and and the lawyer for the
the Pastor said why did you do that were
you afraid of the church she said no she
said she did it for the media
she testified under oath that she
brought armed police to the church as a
sort of shock and awe to please the
media the hyenas of the media who wanted
to see this church knuckle under and to
intimidate those within the church she
did not need to bring armed police to
the church she chose to and and one of
the problems here Dave is a year ago I
think most police would have been
uncomfortable being ticket writers for
public health matters in fact you saw
the New York police department and other
departments saying we're not going to be
your Mass police we're going after the
real crime but in Canada and in some
parts of the UK and Australia police
that had qualms about it well now a year
later that cement has hardened and they
love this new policing taking batons to
the head of guys who don't wear a mask
oh you're not social distancing I'm
going to hit you with a put with a
police baton the the cops who said no
what this isn't policing they've either
quit being reassigned or or just have
taken a back seat the cops who are out
there police I mean enforcing Health
orders that is not a crime that's a
serious problem that is a move literally
to a police state policemen have no
legal authority to implement Public
Health laws they never have you didn't
have actual cops with guns giving
restaurants uh you know or you we see a
mouse under your fridge we you were
shutting your restaurant down for it
wasn't an armed cop we have militarized
this pandemic and where are the Civil
Libertarians Dave listen I mean this is
consistent with sort of what I would say
is the general collapse of the liberal
left in America but I'm glad you
mentioned this idea of you know what the
cops would have done or wouldn't have
done a year ago versus now because it's
like I keep telling people a year and a
half ago we were all living our old
lives and wouldn't we love to go back to
that but it just ain't coming back and
people forget what happened two weeks
ago and then it just kind of keeps
moving I want to give you all a chance
to give a closing statement Kayla you've
been sort of the the most pollyanish the
most positive about this so after
listening to these two guys are you
still there
well to be a little bit more positive
about the police situation uh when they
announced the second stay-at-home
mandate in Ontario the Toronto police
did tweet out they said that the police
had the ability to stop and question
people about why they were outside their
house so you could potentially get
questioned by why you were outside your
house which is ridiculous and the
Toronto police on Twitter did tweet out
we will not be doing that which was a
kind of a direct response to this is
what the police should be doing no we're
not going to do that so I still have
some hope there but then there have been
instances of police officers ticketing
children in parks so
it's a bit of a disaster closing
statement
um I really hope they roll out the
vaccines properly and everything goes
back to normal but I don't I'm skeptical
about the direction America is heading
into like North America I don't know how
things are going to look in the next
couple of years so
um I don't I have no idea Dave I have no
idea how things are going to turn out
she's positive but skeptical Viva
well I am positively skeptical but I am
I I keep saying you know it has to get
um indescribably bad it has to get
intolerably bad before the silent
majority who are there just hoping
things get better quickly uh realize
that they have to be more proactive in
their voicing and be proactive um as far
as elections go but it has to get bad
enough that even the people who are in
the middle realize that the world is
Shifting around them and whether they
like it or not it's going to continue
unless they start to uh make changes at
The Ballot Box and make changes in terms
of public sentiment uh but when I hear
our health director or I forget who it
is talking about a QR code for proof of
vaccine you know I think we're heading
in the wrong direction but you have to
head too far in the wrong direction
before you realize you have to turn back
and I think most people are going to
realize that sooner than later and I
just can't wait for the next elections
yeah well it starts with a QR code next
thing you know they're ripping your
eyeball out and replacing it with
something that they can scan uh Ezra
bring us home
you know almost a century ago Detroit
was America's leading City by some
measures highest industrial wage
cultural capital Motown it was the place
to be now look at it that's bad
political decisions Toronto Canada the
fourth largest city in North America a
great City in many ways but Justin
Trudeau just announced he's planning a
pandemic response well into 2024 and the
lockdowns are getting harsher and
harsher you can destroy a city a
province a whole country look at
Argentina look at Venezuela I am deeply
saddened what's happening in Canada I I
don't see this Sunrise compared Toronto
with Miami
Miami healthy free growing modern upbeat
Toronto Sullen snitch culture informants
brutal police I think that Americans
should know what's going on north of the
Border it is an experiment it is a
laboratory experiment and if you don't
be careful down south my friends the bad
ideas up here could take root down there
and I'm sorry to be so black pilled but
our reporters have been jailed
for what we've talked about here today
so I I'm not feeling optimistic all
right well listen you guys are all doing
great work we are going to link to the
the crowdfunding for the pastor we'll
link to that down below uh and Ezra I'm
going to help you in this fight against
PayPal in any way that I possibly can I
thank you guys I'm going to continue and
don't worry even though you black pilled
everyone there I'm gonna spend the next
two minutes trying to get everybody into
the pleasant weekend mode that's that's
what I do sorry I did that no no no no
look it's real and that's why I wanted
to do this and and the fact that they're
pushing you know all of you good-natured
Canadians you know into becoming you
know crazy radical Freedom extremists
maybe that's the Silver Lining maybe
that really is it well I thank you guys
for doing the show have a good weekend
and I'm just going to finish up by
myself over here for a moment so look
you know I think Ezra really just nailed
it right there at the end and that's
exactly why I wanted to do this show I I
truly love Canada I've been to Canada
probably maybe two dozen times in my
life and and Jordan and I did a bunch of
shows up there and as I said I did some
events with Maxine Bernier two three
years ago who leads the People's Party
of Canada which in essence is their
libertarian party and he was warning
about all of this and warning about
cancel culture and warning against about
antifa and identity politics and all of
these things and it's all here and now
there are these Draconian lockdowns and
and as I said before I don't like to do
the oh these people are Nazi thing right
because we all get these horrible labels
put on us but at some point you know the
Nazis didn't just show up one day it
wasn't just oh congratulations here we
are we weren't here yesterday there was
no sign that any of this was coming it's
like what what allows for that
the Nazis who are the National
socialists by the way right we've got
the Democratic socialists they're the
national they were the national
socialists it's a slow creep of people
being quiet about things everyone
knowing something's wrong and no one
doing what's right so these are just a
couple of the people that are up in
Canada fighting for what's right and and
rebel especially I just think is just
doing great stuff and this PayPal
situation I mean think about it what
Ezra's telling you is his company which
has existed as an independent journalist
outfit for the last eight years I think
it's about eight years and he said
they've done about eight million dollars
175
000 transactions on PayPal something
like that just out of nowhere PayPal can
just boot them sorry you're gone that's
it no recourse and it's like now you got
to fight legally and maybe the legal
means are all we have left anyway I
wanted to do this because I think it's
important to talk about other countries
outside of the United States obviously
and and the things that are happening in
every Western Country right now are are
happening across borders and we live in
a time with social media that what
happens there whatever there is it
doesn't stay there it comes here and we
export we from an American perspective
export a lot of this nonsense sense and
uh we gotta fight guys and I and I hope
you will fight and and all that being
said I am hopeful because people are
waking up as Viva said there you know
you can push and push and push and push
but then eventually people push back and
I did sense this week that there was a
little bit more of a pushback you know
uh Chris Ruffo who's doing some great
work with some uh lawsuits fighting in
the states to get crit uh critical race
Theory out of some of the state
curriculums they got a couple wins in
the last week or two like there are some
good things happening but those good
things they start and they end with us
because it ain't going to be the
politicians that fix this on that note
guys I want you to all have a great
weekend uh actually my brother is
visiting this weekend so we are not
doing a show on Monday I'm taking a rare
day off like a actual day off we will
not have a live stream on Monday but
I'll be back on on Tuesday and then I'm
going to Dallas for a couple days going
to do some stuff with the blaze uh but
I'm just gonna eat some good food and
drink some good drink and you know relax
this weekend I hope you'll do the same
and I'll see you next week and thanks
for watching and have a good day oh and
if you want to see what I'm eating and
what I'm drinking and the other stuff
that I'm doing
reubenreport.locals.com thanks everybody